howard de petits veinards ça profite des
vacances je vous vois venir
je n'ai pas mes lunettes je les adore
tout le monde les écouter aujourd'hui on
va rester dans le thème des vacances
mais d'abord dans quel team a dit est-ce
que vous en vacances vous rejoignez de
la famille quelque part en france dans
leur maison est ce que vous louez à
erbil mais où est-ce que vous louez une
chambre d'hôtel moi je vous cache pas
quand je voyageais un méga kif c'est
découvrir des hôtels j'adore ça quand je
pars en vacances je loue une chambre
d'hôtel et je suis heureux chez pas fort
et je me sens trop bien dans un hôtel
aujourd'hui on va passer en revue plein
de trucs que des gens ont découvert en
arrivant en vacances donc ça va être
pour la plupart des trucs dans leur
chambre d'hôtel des fonctionnalités
auquel ne s'attendaient pas bref j'ai
passé les vacances j'ai envie qu'on
tchèque des trucs en rapport avec les
vacances donc c'est parti pour ça tout
d'abord cet hôtel en islande qui a un
bouton spécial sur le téléphone de la
chambre d'hôtel qui sert à ce qu'on te
préviennent en cas d'aurore boréale
j'ai la haine je suis allé une fois en
islande y avait ni le bouton sur le
téléphone ni des aurores boréales j'ai
rien vu ça fait pas mal cher island et
j'apprécie l'option j'apprécie l'effort
vous nous régaler une auberge en suisse
propose suisse tirs au but 3 matches qui
nous restent et avoir un terrasse et qui
n'ont pas eu lieu suisse qu'est ce que
vous avez fait encore les suisses nos
berges en suisse une baignoire sur rails
frérot achète une piscine gonflable chez
pas gens ça va plus vite non excusez-moi
je suis rabat-joie suppose moi tu me
mets là dedans c'est un traumatisme que
tu craches pas envie qu'on me vois dans
mon bain quoi je sais pas à attention
c'est le retour des boutons spécifiques
sur les téléphones des chambres d'hôtel
voilà l'essentiel fin du sport fin du
summer body l'accès aux pizzas n'a
jamais été aussi simple
la porte de ma salle de bains dans ma
chambre d'hôtel peuvent fermer deux
endroits différents
éclatée qu'est ce que je fais si j'ai
envie d'aller aux toilettes pendant que
ma copine a envie de se changer et qui
est un ami avec nous dans la chambre
[Musique]
ah bah non c'est bon fermez les yeux
vous êtes apaisé vous entendez le bruit
de la mer et des mouettes
dans quelques instants vous allez
retournez à votre chambre d'hôtel et y
découvrir une serviette de bain
soigneusement pliées par le staff
visualiser cette serviette de bain à
quoi ressemble-t-elle à ça mon pote tu
es ma comme le staff est chaud mecque le
fou rire que j'aurais découvrir ça ils
ont même mis des stickers aux yeux des
curieux quelle attention particulière à
les décrocher la lune pour celui que tu
aimes ou pliées des serviettes en forme
de créatures ichi tout ce qu'on choisit
la deuxième option épouse et moi à temps
qu'est ce que c'est que ça alors elle
m'a mis à un tuto pour faire un truc
avec mes lorraine les activités
manuelles il ya plus on a dit qu'on a
arrêté s'était trop catastrophique ça
prend du temps dans les rares fois où
j'ai une serviette origami dans ma
chambre j'étais choqué c'est l'agent
rousseau
c'est tellement de taf c'est tellement
mignon l'éléphant attend aller il faut
se calmer là ok ok ok je vois je vous
parle pas mal c'est quoi la suite d'un
squale animal d'après leur a tant à quoi
ressemble au l'add on passe du signora
mec papa fou de voir une serviette
rassure-t-on il y en a mais bon ça c'est
vraiment quand tu es un connard que tu
appelles beaucoup la réception ils font
leur aaa si un jour vous louer une
chambre d'hôtel et que vous découvrez
une serviette origami là sur le lit vous
savourez beaucoup plus seconde langue
avant hier vous avez vu le taf que c'est
franchement dans mes lui attend dé lui
lui c'est vraiment le bosc n'y a pas un
tuteur pour faire lui je lui parlerai
moi ce serait mon confident pendant mon
voyage dans cet hôtel je me retiendrais
d'aller aux toilettes pendant plusieurs
jours juste pour qu'ils continuent
d'exister
j'ai besoin de lui la vitre de la douche
dans mon hôtel a été découpée pour que
tu puisses l'allumé avant d'entrer
dedans à excuser moi je cherchais à quoi
ça sert mais attends c'est pourquoi les
ingénieurs veulent autant montrer qu'ils
sont ingénieurs aujourd'hui ce ne sont
pas tous des gens qui construisent une
baignoire sur rail pour accomplir leurs
délires exhibitionniste c'est pour
éviter le moment où quand tu allumes la
douche tu te prend de l'eau froide
parce que là ya pas de mot assez de
l'eau qui tombe du plafond en tout cas
je suis content parce que je vais vous
dire un truc sur tous les soucis qui a
en ce moment les quatre secondes de
froide que je me prenais à chaque début
du jeu n'en pouvais plus vraiment je
trouve qu'on n'en parlait pas à si je
suis vraiment ravi qu'ils aient résolu
ce problème j'ai demandé à l'hôtel si je
pouvais ramener mon chat voilà ce qu'on
a découvert en arrivant pas c'est trop
mignon la petite intentions du staff de
l'hôtel
c'est égoïste ils en ont rien à [ __ ]
de toi et de ton chat d'accord rien à
[ __ ] en revanche leur chambre d'hôtel
ils veulent entretenir comme il se doit
ils ont fait ça parce qu'ils ont juste
peur que ton chat peas sur le tapis ou
face ses griffes sur les rideaux
très chaud agressif le miroir de ma
chambre d'hôtel au japon à une partie
chauffante qui fait que la paix ne se
dépose pas dessus après une douche tout
pour éviter l'énergie qu'on dépense dans
le but d'éviter des toutes petites gage
du quotidien qui sont vraiment infimes
genre on peut vivre avec mais ya quand
même des mecs qui sont dit non non non
on est l'humanité on ne vivra plus avec
cette souffrance de pas pouvoir se voir
dans le miroir pendant quatre minutes
après la douche c'est mort mon rêve
ultime
attention on va découvrir le rêve de
l'om accrochez-vous bien 3 2 un jeu
paraît que c'est un truc sous l'eau
let's go up
wa quels by mecque le blème c'est que je
trop cartésien c'est comme la fête
foraine
je vais me dire mi hauteur assise de
profondeur d'eau à un grand débat sur
les vitres et magie de la vitre lnh
pendant que je dors au pc de la cèze de
pixman voilà comment je sors de la gdc
dette insupportable aujourd'hui je
commence quand ma mère elle en pouvait
plus quand j'étais plus jeune je trouve
ça magnifique mais d'un autre côté je
trouve ça angoissant manga ça soumise
aux maximiser le truc et un bouton sur
le téléphone du cou ou quand appuie
dessus ça l'âge de la nourriture aux
poissons et c'est des extras genre à
chaque fois que tu appuies sur le bouton
tu dépends 5 euros mais tu vois des
poissons qui viennent manger je dis ça
en mode blague mais ça se trouve ça
existe totalement et je suis à côté de
la plaque constamment un signe
historique dans mon hôtel explique
comment utiliser l'électricité au cas où
tu n'en avais jamais utilisé avant hu
mais non cette chambre est équipée avec
edison electric light n'essayez pas
d'allumer élan poule avec une allumette
tournées simplement la clé dans le mur à
côté de la porte 1 c'est vrai c'est
génial qui à une époque à des mecs qui a
allumé des allumettes et qu'il est
rapproché des ampoules en pensant que
c'était des lanternes quoi sarko ça
c'est un truc sur lesquels je fasse
défaut d'y à des mecs ont vécu des
évolutions qui pour nous sont tellement
acquise eu un matin il se lève et on
leur dit bah voilà la lumière les
allumettes les trucs et où c'est un peu
galère maintenant il ya juste un
interrupteur tu fais ça et ça s'allume
tout seul
ça c'était la réaction de mon
arrière-arrière-grand-père nous là on
est jeune on fait les malins on est on
prend en main très facilement les choses
on est né aussi là dedans dans l'arrivée
d'internet et tout mais quand on va
vieillir il ya des technologies qui vont
arriver est ce que l'on sera genre out à
quel moment il ya une techno qui va
arriver elle sera trop futur pour nous
et on n'arrivera plus à suivre est ce
que ça va nous arriver je me demande
vraiment ça en ce moment j'en sais quoi
la suite l'hôtel où je suis resté le
week-end dernier à un frigo juste à côté
de la douche
j'avoue des fois je vais sous la douche
et je me dis [ __ ] là je ne boirai bien
une petite bière là 21h tout seul dans
ma douche ce serait vachement agréable
quand même ben apparemment il ya un mec
qui s'est déjà dit ça et sera jeu il a
mis un frigo dans le mur à côté de la
douche d'accord je me rends compte que
les ingénieurs ils sont ils sont
dangereux quand même parce que quand ils
se disent mais pourquoi on ferait pas ça
pour répondre à ce petit besoin ils le
font après ils vont nous on s'arrête au
stade de j'ai eu l'idée c'est bon je
suis content au nouvel ennemi apparaît
le crabe
pas mal pour moi je le mets juste après
le truc sur les toilettes de tout à
l'heure il est vraiment pas mal j'aime
beaucoup j'aime énormément les lunettes
vraiment c'est une petite touche
particulière que j'apprécie les servent
et origami saint-guen qu'on prend très à
coeur l'hôtel où je séjourne à un varan
qui errent dans le parc et nagent dans
la piscine watts vous avez aperçu est
notre invité spécial et au 6ème nager et
les bains de soleil
les warrants et non pas les variants ça
c'est beaucoup moins sympa sont
inoffensifs et ne doivent pas être
approché combattu ou nourris s'il vous
plaît respectez les ai juste apprécier
les observer dans leur habitat naturel
[Musique]
je veux alors j'ai un peu vécu ça et
c'était un moment incroyable en
guadeloupe vous savez en 2008 quand j'ai
fait le tour de francophonie pour vous
rencontrer et très souvent autour de la
piscine de l'hôtel dans lequel on était
il y avait des iguanes des iguanes
d'ailleurs choix qu'on dise pas d iguane
ce que tous les bonnes pioches foutait
de ma gueule donc c'est des iguanes et
fait pas les malins les guadeloupéens
jugement bannière de 3 de la chaîne las
il faut pour les plus commentés aux
mondieux un nouvel opposant approche il
est incroyable j'apprécie le fait qu'ils
aient mis un jouet de la petite fille
dans la gueule du croco les lunettes de
soleil toujours pour rendre le truc
crédible incroyable top indirectement la
télé de ma chambre
alors ça au nom mon frérot opus n'a même
pas eu les saf et origami au nom mais
c'est une tablette c'est pas possible
le proprio de l'hôtel il a arraché
l'écran du siège là dans l'avion il a
scotché au mur c'est honteux
non mais pas m'aimer a eu un poster un
truc c'est mieux quoi alors attendez
je tenais là c'est qu'est ce que c'est
que ce bordel c'est un hôtel dans lequel
il ya des canards qui ont une chambre et
du coup tous les jours il traverse le
hall pour rejoindre la fontaine de
l'hôtel
[Musique]
j'ai adoré il marche sur un tapis rouge
pour y vendre leurs meilleurs fontaine
c'est des stars y en a il a refusé un
c'est le fils a dans le groupe il se la
pète ses canaris sont hautains
je vais arriver dans un hôtel cinq
étoiles après une longue journée cinq
étoiles alors ça donne quoi
[Musique]
c'est tellement dangereux
oui c'est l'hôtel de claude françois ou
quoi tiens c'est horrible accapare sont
en train de me renforcer dans quoi ce
que j'avais dans les douches il ya des
ampoules au plafond mais genre dans la
douche
exactement comme la dans la vidéo et à
chaque fois je me dis mais j'espère que
c'est sacrément bien désolé ce truc
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai suivi mes
cours de physique-chimie en cm1 et au +
électricité égal
claude françois et à chaque fois je suis
pas sûr j'ai peur j'ai envie d'appeler
les ingénieurs leur dire arrêtez les
ampoules dans la douche arrêtez s'il
vous plaît mettez là juste hors de la
cabine de douche et sa éclairera dans la
douche puisque c'est transparent voyez
ce que je veux dire le canapé dans notre
chambre d'hôtel et non il ne se sépare
pas en 2 bat mais c'est quoi ce design
mais enfin faut arrêter c'est un canapé
3 places et le troisième il est puni
quoi ya pas de dossier je comprends pas
si quelqu'un a la réponse à cette
question les gars c'est même pas beau en
plus je comprends pas le truc j'ai passé
quinze minutes à chercher une prise dans
ma chambre d'hôtel
la seule que j'ai trouvé se trouve
derrière le radiateur au ça devrait
aller ici ça on refera une vidéo sur
celui-là il c'est un classique il est
incroyable ce couloir d'hôtel à cologne
en allemagne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gerbet ce qu'un point tu rentres de
soirée et tu veux juste attendre ta
chambre tu te tapes une gerbe à cause du
sol attendent dangereux à cause d'un
architecte d'intérieur un peu médiocre
fait chier merde ce n'est pas un bateau
échoué
c'est un hôtel en corée du sud wwa est
ce qu'ils ont construit le truc ici où
est-ce qu'ils ont récupéré un bateau de
croisière qui était en fin de carrière
pour en faire un hôtel ce serait
incroyable et est ce que les billets
sont déjà dormi là large et je m'en bats
les couilles
écoutez c'est la fin de cette vidéo
j'espère qu'elle vous a plu j'ai adoré
découvrir tout ça j'ai passé un très bon
moment et aussi sachez que quoi que vous
fassiez pendant ces vacances ça va être
bien façon toutes les vacances sont bien
ces principes des vacances est toujours
bien vacances vac qui nous vient de ne
rien faire et en ce qui nous vient de
soleil c'est forcément à un mélange de
trucs cool j'ai aucune idée de quand
sortira cette vidéo mais qui fait bien
votre été profitez bien vous l'avez
mérité prenez soin de vous pensez à vous
aussi sachez que dans chaque vidéo là
que j'ai sortir en juillet août je
dirais bonnes vacances
d'accord à chaque fois pour être sûr que
vous passiez de bonnes vacances si je ne
dis pas vous risquez d'en passer des pas
très bonne donc je préfère le dire
douanes va je suis aujourd'hui mardi on
vient de voir que des trucs incroyables
qui me donne envie de partir là aux
aléas très vite l'esprit d'osséja
[Musique]
ça fait quoi main
[Applaudissements]
ça fait pas mal